mandai a tutti i rifornitori vale ciò
oggi vedremo i letti più assurdi più
belli più strani al mondo e nei commenti
potrete lasciare il times stampo potrete
scrivere qual è il letto che vi è
piaciuto di più è quello che mi è
piaciuto di meno una domanda non ci sarà
un letto dove si potrà mangiare ma si
può già a mangiare all'estero tipo
eletto proprio fatto a forma di tavolo
dovete mettere mai intermonte invece sia
molto comodo per dormire
ma vediamo perché ce ne sono tanti mondi
gli apolidi trani noi li abbiamo ancora
visti quindi li vedremo assieme a voi
siete pronti per nessuno patatine
peccato è il fiasco allora 1 il lesso
hamburger cosa che feci tutto questo
stessi anche mangiare che attendevo
questa transumanza però carino per che
altro perché c'è nebbia colpito
l'insalata che la piccola il piccolo
lenzo lino verde a forma di insalata
popolare euro brutto dormirci dentro
perché ti senti un po soffocare maschi
voi che voto date a queste burger
roma gli do un 5 4
allora cos'è il folk rock lo sto usando
a salutare ea chi e poi quelle sono le
coperte loro forza esile sembra molto
comodo però morbidoso si butti
2 lett
numero due tota joia
mi sembra comodissimo non so perché ma
per ora che inizi a terra mi sembrano
più comodi commento burroni giapponesi
mai ammesso legge non a 10 e ti do un 98
in mezzo a voi vero numero 3 il letto
amedo mito
oddio in pratica ci sono le uova e
outdoor ma sembra punto il lido che
carino in particolare non lo so a questo
cuscino
sì forse solo per una persona e come è
stato però rossi non sembra male ha
decorato le uova di pasqua che canino
chi vi do un otto e mezzo su 7
insufficienza numero 4 il letto nello
spazio o spazioso vediamo laziale
[Musica]
in pratica dei di le stelle sopra
ovviamente sono dell'incile wow questo
mi piace tantissimo
ti faccio vedere le stelle ti guardano
di notte che bello molto carino da
questo video originale mondo libero da
un nome di pio ix il letto sedia trash
tra tante questo desire al tipo di
dondolio è un letto dondolo no questo
non mi piace per niente la notte questo
abbozzato di don 3 voi che foto gli date
tutti in quattro perché forse era fuori
casa è bello in effetti dormirei di
notte per dondolarsi un posto bello
numero 6 il letto con la tv integrata
interessante lo dovrebbero fare quella
cucina anche karima bellissimo molto
bello anche se ti senti un po chiuso in
una scatoletta però è aperto ai lati
poi si può anche rialzare per vedere
bene la del beauty vadano bene
nove e mezza in chi è bellissimo
ah ecco e rimane anche un po aperto così
non si sente troppo soffocato il bello
qualche voto gli date numero 7 il letto
per quelli che amano la piccola verso il
letto per te vediamo guardate che carini
soffietto errori e il brocco questi sono
solo lenzuola normali alla fine non è
proprio un letto dal divano diciamo il
primo campione forse per dormirci non è
molto comodo
il resto che è appeso al soffitto come
ti condanna manca per questo in bocca al
giardino si debbano trovarsi però per
essere per rilassarsi ma un porto al
mezzo dai nostri se non è andato il voto
a quello pizza gli dà un set state
rinchiuse noi che voto gli italiani
arrivano ma che bello questi sembra
superconti si chiude esterno dell'occhio
dall'interno diretta questo è carino wow
bello bello ma no il letto con la zip
sarà un sacco a pelo
è così che lo puoi rifare inventare
perché non chiusi dove aprì quindi è già
pronto da subito pronta non devi stare
lì a de carlo
[Musica]
non mi piace tanto questo li do un sei
tu 5 non vuoi che utilizzate
il letto libro vediamo questo è un letto
come in questo letto poi leggere
ovviamente ma sono una pagina ha detto
particolare è carino come voto serve
adesso quanto si accomodano stile dei
poiché voto gli date numero 11 il gatto
gigante il metodo di gatto gb
ciao ogni pupazzo enorme giubbotti
pressione sembra un elefante bellissimo
certo si occupa un pezzo della casa però
che titoli da un 9 anche se non penso
che sia comodo tornarci sopra
io set numero 12 il letto montagna di
stato ma come funziona senza decidere
tutto per metterti io pure durante la
notte
sivori un po non lo so oddio è molto
tranquillo un po particolare dire non
penso che sia molto comodo non lo so
no no questa borsa forti da un patto
tronfio
allora sei divertente da vedere o magari
non per dormire ma per farlo stimolo
tipo non fra 13
il letto in cui può dormire
nell'opposizione effettuato quindi
raggomitolato ma se non ti muovi per
niente mentre dormi potrebbe essere
questo letto si è scritto ma voto 0
vabbè cioè non sa neanche bisogno di
commentarlo numero fattore dissimile
gattorno di liquido ruolo forse come i
letti ad acqua per bruno millesi ad
acqua come spesso rebbe dormire in un
mezzo come questo purtroppo è solo una
foto
il vento tratto remo bello bella idea
effettivamente sì ma dice che puoi anche
guidarlo in camion morti.il tu lo
faresti sempre con te con un tipo dentro
na li priviamo se questa cosa fantastica
rimane sollevato tipo fighissimo cosa un
po particolare problemi che belli volta
io vedo queste foto di camere bellissimo
torino voglia di essere lì per corvette
ma perché è il viaggio è questa ma
questo cosa far guardare la tv tipo
l'intrattenimento creato ti stende
legali la carta
la principessa bellissimo questo sono
quelle che hanno introdotto in alcune
aziende per far dormire lì per i
dipendenti che bello lo sottolineiamo fa
colorado teva o dentro una botte di
legno che coprono bello che cosa di
strano questo letto oltre all'avere 15
cuscini logo spesso l'abbiamo visto
primaria letto che secondo la nota che
questo di legno ecco l thp organizzare
un altro letto rollercoaster non so
perché vada così di moda questo design
letto castello però molto più bello dei
normali letti a castello delle possibili
brose comunque sto molto classico voglia
di essere in una di queste stanze
diviene anche voi questa sensazione di
pokeristi artistica sotto scavati
preferite un po sono tipo tenda in un
ghetto rotondo senza così spazi in
questo detto wow
ma è imperante questo letto c'è e tipo
questo qua e ti butti in mezzo pratico
la una testina dello spazzolino davvero
quel letto spazzolino gigante non solo
tre cose ci pensa con la rete per
dormire sospeso
io mi paure tipo mi sveglia che sembra
che sto per cadere
magari arrivo io e ti taglio tutta
ragazza questo questo letto e per
dormire in piedi sulla torre sembra
anche molto comodo una airbag
guarda questo invece lo sa che materiale
sia sembra fatto di gomma forse bello
però e questo con delle palline di gomma
forse non sembra molto comodo
l'hamburger se anche il toast questa è
un po più duro però se invece il
materasso è questo più rigido vedi ok
quindi meglio eletto hamburger pari a
questo letto in pratica entri dentro e
tipo una una lattina entre deux
continuiamo puoi fare poi girare guerra
se tu cammini gira e si trasforma quasi
eletto giri si trasforma in scrivania
l'unica cosa che devi stare attento a
non appoggiare mai niente o se ne sta
guardando il video di rita storia è
stata per te perché troppo prima di
andare a dormire e vai
altrimenti io poi quando webber e
dormire vai e diventa letto su guarda
questo letto in pratica un letto nel
mezzo di una piscina o quella
televisione è sì avevo paura che cava
qualcosa nella piscina e poi non lo so
forse l'aria che respiri l'ing
molto buona con tutto il cloro esatto e
poi mi da un senso di chiuso
sì molto sofferto fobico voi invece cosa
ne pensate che sensazioni vita al cesso
arrivo io ti prendo e ti butto di rete e
quegli altri che il baretto un po il
letto dentro la bocca del dinosauro è
fatta su perbene 3 l'aglio soprattutto
per chi è appassionato di dinosauri del
salto dello squalo
oddio questo fa un po di impressione
sono del resto questo è un letto una
specie di amaca pro tutta con la rete
attorno non mi piace tantissimo non lo
so anche questo mi da un senso di
intrappolati posti
e voi cosa ne pensate che sensazioni
vida questo letto ma testa non mi piace
come detto dove sembra di essere un
pesce intrappolato in quella meglio il
letto ostrica succede qualcosa poi si
chiude se rimane chiusa la destra di
rosa per sbaglio si chiude ad hoc
la nostra non vi piace tanto e karin
estetica ma c'è una luce penso
all'interno vede adesso alla luce di ciò
io avrei comunque paura che vi cade in
testa mentre voi cosa ne pensate
macchina seika incluso mi piace
tantissimo ma comunque fatta molto bene
questo letto ma che abbiamo questa
salvezza ovvero della macchina cosa che
davvero per appassionati di macchine
permetterselo addirittura nel letto
perché il mio l'oro invece carinissimo
lì
[Musica]
voi cosa ne pensate vi piace questo
design l'ora questo è un letto tondo
anche questo non so se anche questo si
gira o se romane ferma credo che sia un
altra persona possa stare da sola si
sdraia ta con le gambe tutte piegano
questa parte le gambe da questa barca
appoggio rivede il contrario fa ha poi
indicato intelligente come idea però non
so quanto possa essere comodo mi sarei
solo per cioè tipo un divano non è un
letto poi cosa ne pensate vi piace mi
piacerebbe averlo allora questo è un
altro letto botte di legno dormi dentro
queste sono due ragazze ma sempre queste
due ragazze non lo so mi sembra un po
stretto che amber
voi cosa ne pensate il legno audi anche
se davvero legno fatto da parti lese
sotto pressione
oddio questo è un letto per bambini ma
per neonati ma non mi sembra per niente
felice e poi quest'altro letto e un
letto a forma di f di facebook è però fa
anche da vedere la parte sinistra invece
sempre quasi da scrivania
quindi diciamo che ha letto scrivania
non so perché si sta avvenendo sonno
vedere se questi studi sapendo sono
fatti si sta per esempio poi se la
stessa sensazione così rischiate jean
documentati
andando adesso mansur dovete solo vedere
le foto ti fa venire il letto di paglia
mente fosse dormire sulla paglia cioè a
caldo anche la vogliano quindi questa è
una versione moderna del letto di paglia
e anche con i mobili e le piante si
sbaglia molto bene un po scomodo adesso
il divano maiale non so perché mi fa un
po di impressione è anche questo ma ieri
sembra molto triste di dover fare poco
forse era meglio diventare diventare un
frutto da mangiare polverini no mi fa
pena poverino è triste questo maiale
voci limone cipster tavolo mentre si
situi il condimento sei tu dentro kgb è
un po particolare però forse pacman per
cui come pure tutti lì comunque sembra
abbastanza comodo però non capisco
perché abbiamo questo colore giallo il
rosso particolare una nota ebbene design
dei lenti più strani e beh quello che è
piaciuto di più ma simpatico sono
piaciuti ma quello della donna che si
immergeva nel lessico come se fosse
acqua con un più e sarebbe se fosse come
dimostra fondare un rito
e a te aveva quello che mi è piaciuto di
più volte a quello pizza che il
comodissimo secondo me sul divano butti
veloce un piccolo sonnellino quello lì
da un muro che ti guarda che io voglio
fare quello che mi ha chiesto di più
fatecelo sapere nei commenti
e ora vi lasciamo qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
altre reazioni video divertenti
slideshow l'esplicarsi su quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao